in weniger als einer woche haben die
ukrainischen streitkräfte nach
us-angaben mehr gelände zurück erobert
als moskau streitkräfte seit april
besetzt haben darunter auch strategisch
wichtige ortschaften über die die russen
ihren nachschub organisiert hatten wie
haben die ukraine das geschafft hier
sehen wir auf dieser karte wie sich seit
beginn des krieges die verhältnisse
verändert haben zunächst hatten die
russen immer mehr gebiete erobert und
dann sehen wir dass oben im nordosten
das gebiet um kreativ
zurückerobert worden ist wieder in
ukrainischer hand ist es gab offenbar
eine ganz simples täuschungsmanöver auch
dabei wochen lang redeten die ukraine
von einer geplanten offensive im süden
des landes und tatsächlich schlugen sie
dann im nordosten zu
[Musik]
die harte realität des krieges
[Applaus]
ukrainische kräfte attackieren ein
russisches kampf hat zwei russen sterben
ukraine jubeln
die harte realität des krieges
[Musik]
die überraschende realität scheint jetzt
aber auch zu sein der rückgewinn der
ukraine im nordosten ihres landes ist
noch viel größer als zuerst vermutet
anstelle der zuvor berichteten 3000
quadratkilometer sind ist laut präsident
selensky mindestens 6000 bremen und das
saarland zusammen mal zwei neue realität
für die bewohner der kleinen stadt
ballack ihren sie werden nicht mehr von
russen beherrscht und unterdrückt müssen
sich nicht mehr in ihren kellern
verstecken die stadt wurde durch die
gegenoffensive befreit jetzt erreichen
erste hilfsgüter die einwohner ballack
iaas erleichterung nach sieben monaten
besatzung sieben monate in angst
am 9 märz bin ich um circa halb elf ihr
von zu hause losgefahren dann schoss
eine große chance auf mich
die kugel ging hier rein dann durchs
auto und durchschlug neben mir die
windschutzscheibe
nur ein kleines stück daneben und ich
wäre jetzt nicht mehr am leben
wir hatten angst wenn wir schlafen die
gang sind wussten wir nicht ob wir
wieder aufstehen nachts wurde ständig
geschossen tagsüber natürlich auch
wovor haben sie am meisten angst
naja wenn man tot ist ist man tot
schlimm ist es verkrüppelte zu werben
viele leben jetzt ohne arme oder beine
egal wie es vorher in der ukraine war es
war die ukraine ich hatte meine ganze
verwandtschaft vor sieben monaten kam
eine urenkelin zur welt die ich bis
jetzt noch nie gesehen
die russen haben sich teils sogar über
die grenze ins eigene land zurückgezogen
offiziell um sich zu regieren
die harte realität des krieges hier in
ballack lea blitzt aber auch ein stück
hoffnung auf eine neue realität durch
ein leben in sicherheit und ohne
russische besatzung
ich halte mir zu unserem reporter paul
ronzheimer der in einem gebiet ist
östlich von prag dass die ukrainischen
streitkräfte befreit haben von den
russischen besatzern paul was erzählen
dir die bewohner über die russischen
soldaten was es in der zeit der
besatzung dort alles passiert
herr thomas es war wirklich berührend
dort unterwegs zu sein und gleichzeitig
auch schockieren als wir dort hinkommen
wo das essen ausgegeben wurde sind
menschen zusammengebrochen viele alte
menschen man sieht kaum junge männer und
fragt sich natürlich wo sind die sind
die möglicherweise erschossen wurden von
den russischen truppen dort gleichzeitig
große freude von den ukrainern die dort
sind die gesagt haben als wir die
ukrainische truppen gesehen haben da
haben wir vor freude geweint und
gleichzeitig horrorgeschichten über das
was ihnen angetan wurde sie berichteten
von wahllosen verhaftungen davon dass
die russen sich die sachen einfach
genommen haben die sie wollten und dann
eben von der russischen flucht in den
vergangenen tagen aber man spürt immer
noch den schock bei den menschen die
angst die so schnell nicht weggehen wird
paul diese gewinne diese befreiung des
eigenen landes den ukrainern gelungen
dort ist haben so ein bisschen die
tektonik in der strategie natürlich auch
wieder verändert wir bekommen gerade die
anmeldung dass bundeskanzler olaf scholz
den gesprächsfaden mit putin auch wieder
aufgenommen hat auch der russische
außenminister lawrow hatte ja gestern
schon eine neue verhandlungsbereitschaft
angekündigt ich sag dir mal kurz in dem
90-minütigen gespräch zwischen stolz und
putin das übrigens nach einem gespräch
mit dem ukrainischen präsidenten sie
lenski stattgefunden hat soll scholz auf
eine diplomatische lösung gedrungen habe
die auf einen waffenstillstand einen
vollständigen rückzug der russischen
truppen und die achtung der
territorialen integrität und
souveränität der ukraine basiere deiner
einschätzung von vor ort
das wird putin nicht umsetzen er hat er
in den vergangenen tagen gesagt dass er
die sogenannte spezialoperation weiter
durchführen wird ich nehme an in diesem
telefonat zwischen putin und scholz wird
es wieder auch um waffenlieferungen
gegangen sein denn das ist ja das was
jetzt kommen könnte bzw der druck auf
scholz wird immer größer dass der
deutsche panzer hierher liefern sollte
und wir erinnern uns thomas und das ist
ganz wichtig am anfang des krieges gab
es diese telefonate zwischen putin und
scholz auch immer wieder und unter
anderem wird auf ein solches telefonat
bezug genommen weshalb scholz nicht
schon schneller und härter reagiert hat
und nicht früher waffen geschickt hat
also möglicherweise könnte auch dass ein
zusammenhang seien die ukraine selbst
werden nicht bereit seien gebiete
abzugeben oder zu sagen okay da wo wir
jetzt stehen die russen bekommen wie
auch immer man das formuliert im osten
etwas und wir ziehen uns dahin zurück
nein man hat das gefühl die ukraine
glauben jetzt an ihrem momentum ob das
wirklich so lange durchzuhalten ist dass
es offen aber sie glauben daran und
wollen weitere gebiete zurückerobern
paul ronzheimer in der ukraine vielen
dank
[Musik]